et il y avait lui son père sur moi en
fait avec une amie moi j'appelle ça un
burin parce qu'ils avaient un espèce de
petit marteau il m'avait endormi toute
la bouche avec plusieurs piqûres et
taper taper taper jusqu'à que ça sorte
qu'il y avait un truc qui se passait je
les ai vu ce concerter puis demander ce
qu'il y avait il m'avait dit qu'il y a
une banque avec AC et cette dent était
vraiment nécessaire pour tenir le bridge
en fait c'est il a fait tout en un bloc
en fait c'est même pas dans pardon comme
ce qui est conseillé et il m'a dit ça
tiendra pas je préfère te dire un moment
donné ça va casser par la suite j'ai des
greffé osseuses à faire c'est infesté de
kyste
partout on peut plus manger c'est que
liquide faut toujours faire attention on
a toujours peur ben que parce qu'on se
retrouve sans rien il y a tout qui part
c'est plus de 10 ans que vous viviez
plus quoi en fait c'est ça prenez des
antidouleurs j'imagine mais les
antidouleurs ils font pleurer au bout
d'un moment moi on m'a expliqué que
fallait que je me prépare
psychologiquement même à ce que mon
visage soit déformé parce que quand ça
touche le devant du visage quand ils
vont devoir creuser je vais devoir
préparer à me regarder quoi